>> AN UNNAMED OFFICER TOLD THE
COMMITTEE THAT GOP SENATOR JOSH
HAWLEY'S FIST PUMP OUTSIDE THE
CAPITOL RILED UP THE CROWD
OUTSIDE THAT DAY.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE IN THIS PHOTO,
HE RAISED HIS FIST IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE PROTESTERS.
ALREADY AMASSING AT THE
SECURITY GATES.
WE SPOKE WITH THE CAPITOL
POLICE OFFICER WHO WAS OUT
THERE AT THE TIME.
SHE TOLD US THAT SENATOR
HAWLEY'S GESTURE RILED UP THE
CROWD.
AND IT BOTHERED HER GREATLY.
BECAUSE HE WAS DOING IT IN A
SAFE SPACE.
PROTECTED BY THE OFFICERS AND
THE BARRIERS.
LATER THAT DAY, SENATOR HAWLEY
FLED AFTER THOSE PROTESTERS HE
HELPED TO RILE UP STORMED THE
CAPITOL.
SEE FOR YOURSELF.
>> SO, HE'S RUNNING AWAY, RIGHT?
HE'S OUT THERE FIST PUMPING,
THEN YOUR RUNNING INSIDE THE
CAPITOL TO TRY AND PROTECT THE
PEOPLE.
INSIDE OF THE CAPITAL.
AFTER HE DOES THIS FIST PUMP
LIKE HE'S SO BRAVE AND SO
STRONG, WHAT DID YOU THINK OF
THE?
>> I THOUGHT HE RAN LIKE A
COWARD, LIKE MANY PEOPLE IN
TRUMP WORLD, HE PERFORMS WHEN
HE'S IN FRONT OF A CAMERA, AND
HE ACTS VERY DIFFERENTLY WHEN
HE IS NOT.
>> DON'T YOU THINK THAT IS A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO DID
SIMILAR, WHO VOTED NOT TO
CERTIFY THE ELECTION, WHO ARE
STILL DENYING THAT IT WAS AN
INSURRECTION, OR THAT THERE WAS
--
THAT THE ELECTION WAS, YOU KNOW,
FAIR?
DO YOU HAVE THAT SAME SENTIMENT
ABOUT THEM, BECAUSE THEY DID
SIMILAR THINGS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I DRAW THE PARALLEL SOMETIMES
WHEN I TALK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
AND HIS RELATIONSHIP TO VINCE
MCMAHON.
WHO, IF YOU'RE NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE WONDERFUL WORLD OF
WRESTLING, WHICH I AM FROM A
YOUTH, DONALD TRUMP KIND OF
BROUGHT THEM VINCE MCMAHON
PLAYBOOK INTO HIS WORLD OF
POLITICS, AND THAT, YOU HAVE
THESE INDIVIDUALS LIKE AUDREY
TAYLOR GREENE AND JOSH HAWLEY,
THAT PLAY A CHARACTER AND
BEHAVE A CERTAIN WAY IN FRONT
OF THE CAMERA, BECAUSE THEY
KNOW IT DRAWS ATTENTION AND
THEY KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF AMERICANS OUT THERE THAT
REACT TO THAT, UNFORTUNATELY,
IN A POSITIVE WAY.
>> WELL, AS WE CALL IT DOWN
SOUTH, ALL HAT AND NO CATTLE,
ALL STYLE AND NO SUBSTANCE.
THANK YOU, WE APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU DID WITH WHAT YOU DID FOR A
SOMEWHAT YOU'RE DOING FOR US
HERE ON CNN CNN AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
>> AND TRUMP WASN'T THE ONLY
2024 CANDIDATE THAT WAS KIND OF
ALLUDED TO LAST NIGHT.
JOSH HAWLEY IS ALSO SOMEONE WHO
IS RUMORED TO POTENTIALLY RUN
AND THE COMMITTEE WENT OUT OF
THEIR WAY --
>> NO PUN INTENDED.
SORRY.
>> YEAH, RUNNING IN TWO
DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE COMMITTEE WENT OUT OF THEIR
WAY TO SHOW THIS VIDEO OF HAWLEY
WHO EARLIER IN THE DAY HAD
PUMPED A FIST AT THE RIOTERS
RUNNING THROUGH THE HALLS OF THE
SENATE, YOU CAN SEE HIM THERE ON
THE RIGHT AS HE COMES DOWN THE
STAIRS, RUNNING AS ALL OF THESE
LAWMAKERS WERE ESCAPING THE
RIOTERS THAT WERE DESCENDING ON
THE CAPITOL.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, THERE'S ALSO VIDEO FROM
WITHIN THE ROOM OF THE HEARING
ROOM WHERE WHEN HE IS SHOWN
RUNNING ACROSS THE SENATE FLOOR
EVERYONE BURSTS INTO LAUGHTER.
IT WAS COMPLETELY GRATUITOUS.
JOSH HAWLEY HAD REALLY NOTHING
TO DO WITH THIS BUT THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO MAKE THE
POINT THAT IF YOU ARE GOING TO
BE ON THE SIDE OF EVIL IN THIS,
YOU'RE GOING TO BE EXPOSED.
AND SO MAYBE IT'S FOR 2024 OR
MAYBE IT'S JUST BECAUSE HE WAS
RILING UP THE CROWD BEFOREHAND
AND THEN AS SOON AS THE CROWD
CAME IN HE STARTED RUNNING LIKE
A BABY AWAY.
BUT IT WAS -- IT WAS PRETTY
COMICAL.
THE OTHER THING THAT REALLY
JUMPS OUT NOW IS WHAT HAPPENS
WITH MIKE PENCE?
THE EVIDENCE IS SO STRONG THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS TRYING TO PUT
MIKE PENCE IN JEOPARDY AND MIKE
PENCE HAS HAD HIS LAWYER
TESTIFY, HIS CHIEF OF STAFF
TESTIFY, BUT HE HAS THUS FAR, WE
UNDERSTAND, RESISTED TESTIFYING.
I THINK THESE EIGHT HEARINGS
RATCHET UP THE PRESSURE ON MIKE
PENCE TO COME IN AND TO EXPLAIN
WHAT HIS PERSPECTIVE THAT DAY.
>> PENCE WAS A HERO OF JANUARY
6th AND WE SAW MORE OF THAT
TODAY WHEN YOU HAD THAT -- THEY
PUT TOGETHER THE MOSAIC OF
EVIDENCE YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW
CLOSE THE CROWD CAME TO HIM AND
THE ALARM AND THE DANGER, THE
RADIO TRANSMISSIONS, THE DANGER.
BUT HE AND THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY -- AND THIS IS WHAT
KINZINGER WHEN HE SAID IT'S
STILL OUT THERE AND WHAT CHENEY
WAS TALKING ABOUT AT THE END OF
THE HEARING -- HE AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAVE NOT REALLY
COME TO GRIPS WITH WHAT IS STILL
OUT THERE AND THEY'RE DOING THIS
TRIANGULATION.
CIPOLLONE DID IT, TOO.
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO STAND BEHIND
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
HE WANTED TO DO ENOUGH TO AVOID
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT, BUT NOT SO
MUCH AS TO PISS OFF DONALD
TRUMP.
THAT IS A TEST OF COURAGE THAT
MIKE PENCE IS NOW --
>> AND BY THE WAY, I THINK VERY
QUICKLY EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE GOES
AWAY WHEN DOJ GETS TO CIPOLLONE.
>> IF.
>> WELL, I THINK THEY WILL.
>> WELL, I THINK.
>> WHY?
>> THERE IS NO EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE FOR MISCONDUCT.
THERE IS NO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
TO CONCEAL WRONGDOING AND THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT TRUMP'S
DERELICTION OF DUTY AND HIS
REFUSAL TO DO ANYTHING IS
WRONGDOING.
THIS GOES BACK TO THE NIXON
CASE.
SO I THINK THE DOJ WILL BE ABLE
TO PIERCE THAT PRIVILEGE VEIL
AND TELL GET FROM CIPOLLONE ALL
THE TESTIMONY.
>> IT WOULDN'T BE A DAN AND NORM
GET TOGETHER IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
AT LEAST ONE DISAGREEMENT.
WE'RE FRIENDS BUT WE DEBATE.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT DOJ DID,
DAN, WITH MEADOWS, WITH SCAVINO
WHERE THEY FAILED TO CHARGE, I
THINK THAT THERE IS A SERVE
TICHL WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
I FOUGHT WITH THEM WHEN I WAS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, AT THE OFFICE
OF LEGAL COUNSEL, THEY ARE SO
PROTECTIVE, TOO PROTECTIVE OF
THE PREROGATIVES OF THE
PRESIDENCY.
I THINK THAT THEY MAY TREAD A
LITTLE MORE LIGHTLY LOOKING
AHEAD TO A NEW CONGRESS THAT IS
GOING TO TARGET JOE BIDEN AND
HIS ADMINISTRATION WHERE THEY'RE
GOING TO WANT TO USE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AS A SHIELD.
SO I THINK IT MAY BE A SLIGHTLY
MORE COMPLICATED CALCULUS.